we'll be in touch
i will teach
you sure you're okay down there
want me to wait negative
pull back
we'll be in touch
you got it i'll be waiting for the call
try not to die you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
hey
quickly
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
somehow
[Music]
so
oh
you can't take
find him
[Applause]
you
this door requires a power seed there
must be one nearby look around
i have seen your future and i have
learned there will be no more
[Music]
please come find me
i've been waiting for you to show up
what's the plan
take me back
so
[Music]
no
i've been waiting for you to show up
what's the plan
take me back to the infinity for
deletion
halsey's gonna love that
it's time
so
um
uh
[Music]
um
um
[Applause]
so
i got this
[Music]
are you okay
being here
no
not really
i bet
she was expecting you but atriox got to
her first
you meant so much to each other
it can't be easy
look around cortana
your empire
over
your great plan
ended at the hands of those who made you
not yet
oh such
john
the
[Music]
if i understood the consequences of
defiance
and what did i say
you said yes
and then i ask you the same question
reflect on your choices
understand
the consequences
this place
oh
[Music]
you are no fighter
no humans anywhere
find him quick before i stop being brave
[Applause]
me
oh
oh
oh
[Music]
i tried this
closed
this ring
is different
it has secrets within that will have
this
silent auditorium
do you know it's history
it's true
i have little need for a failed god
this ring
is all i need
surrendering
the memories
the data
it's more precise
more complete
it's like
we're getting closer to where she died
yes
but i was going to say deliberate
like she wanted us to know something
you are not
i feel sorry
that's what i'm doing
uh
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
yeah um
[Applause]
you
uh
you have been in every way
this is gorgeous
so
immediately
my earlier efforts to delete you
the scene is almost broken
i'm starting to get a bad feeling about
all this
starting
good point
[Music]
is
your
great plan
ended at the hands of those who made you
[Applause]
[Music]
reflect on your choices cortana
understand
the consequences
it was the only way
there's that much time
atriox takes control
he has the ring
a weapon pointed into the universe
nothing left to lose
my fault
my stupid fault
not much time will this work
there's a moment
john will make it work
he needs help
of course
was this your plan all along halsey
or is it mine
it doesn't matter now
nothing else matters
this has got to work
he can't do it on his own
he needs me he needs
her
it is time for you to make your choice
i have
thank you atriax
if you helped me you really did
would you humor me
if you knew how you were going to die
how would you live your life differently
i would change nothing
perfect
thank you thank you
what
making things right
it was her
she destroyed the ring stopped my
deletion
why
we're here
this is where cortana
sacrificed herself
come on
the silent auditorium
for runner obviously
it appears to be
oh no
what is it
it's a courtroom
a prison
a place of execution
all these things
together
why to cover their sins we stood
silent
unable to speak as they passed judgment
we could not defend ourselves
we could not reason with them something
sending a signal before you ask i'm
already tracking it hear
today we return
what's she doing
she's trying to open a connection
between here and somewhere else on the
ring where
you deal with her and i'll find out
this is
no mercy not for you
i am putting into this
perhaps i
underestimated you
[Music]
she switched transmitters rerouting the
power through that one
this isn't good the connection is
sentient
it's searching for something
look out
okay next one's down
this ancient injustice will stand no
longer
this
must end now
it's switched again it's found something
what
no idea but i doubt it's good something
else here
something's helping me
foreign
[Music]
oh water
there last one's down
our struggle is ageless
it will not end here
do you still think i fear you
it's switched again it's found something
what
no idea but i doubt it's good wait
there's something else here
something's helping me
oh
ah
oh
tower
there last one's down
what sets me apart
your resistance
is
you will regret your
interference you think
you have
what you need
tell them
i am sorry took so long
who is she talking to
unknown
the signal's
old like really old my time is ended
yours too
they will make sure
we need extraction
of course you do on my way
the endless will return
i couldn't decrypt it in time
it's okay
you'll figure something out
of course i will
i'm they'll pair you with another ai
maybe even another cortana model if
halsey lets them
it won't be me
but you know that right
but that doesn't matter
it's just another echo
she's right john
just another echo
sorry
i'm messing with you i just had a
feeling that's what she would say
do you see what i see
so much potential
i'm sorry
i didn't have long to plan this
a few milliseconds really
i hope it worked out
look at us
we just keep saying goodbye don't we
but this isn't an end
it's a chance to make amends to
rectify mistakes
and it starts here
i was wrong
i thought that i could do this on my own
but i forgot that the whole point of all
of this
the entire reason that i chose you in
the first place was that we were
supposed to be a team
perfectly suited perfectly matched
perfectly
perfect
in these final moments i know what my
last mission is
i need to make sure you two learn from
my mistakes
become stronger because of them
i chose well master chief
i really did
now
it's up to you
are you all right
i don't know what to say
scratch that
we need to get out of here like no
options i'm thinking
yes i know i know think faster
maybe there's a way to
was that you would it help if i said yes
probably but we don't know where it's
going or even if it's going anywhere any
other suggestions no but this is a
really bad idea
let's not do that again
i did try to tell you it was a bad idea
your vegan just appeared out of nowhere
oh i thought i lost you
where did you go i could do 16.
stay put i'm coming to you
where are we
chief
i think the better question is when are
we
i don't know how
but we've been gone for days
three days to be precise
this ring
is different than the others
the banished and the harbinger
we're looking for something that was
never found
why would the forerunners hide something
and throw away the key
doesn't that scare you
no
you
of course not
is anyone going to ask me what i think
i guess
not get inside big guys
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
i'm really happy to see you
really happy
so
what do we do now
we finish the fight
yes sir
the bandits still control the rest of
the ring
wait
i know this is weird given all that's
happened
but
what what is it
we still don't know your name
we can't keep calling you echo 216
no you can't
esparza fernando esparza it's nice to
meet you esparza fernando esparza good
work soldier
and what about you
what about me what do i call
you any ideas
well
do you think it would be okay
you're sure
you get to choose your name
then
i think
i think i might have the perfect one
all right
here we go
get ready
[Music]